when you're working with a writer can
you explain how you reverse engineer
their path forward
so in some situations
i like to think about where i want to be
and i start there
and then i walk backwards so you're
thinking
what kind of
producer
or director or actor is he like to
collaborate with
you know what are your references to
other movies that are in this space
so you might be thinking
the expectation of the fans of a genre
you might be thinking
the scope of a movie
for example there are horror films that
are made
for a hundred thousand dollars some of
them are made for a few million
and then there's bigger budget ones that
are mid-range which are in a whole other
category
so
i want to know
what model are we working in the last
thing you'd want to do is get a script
that's unproducible
where the budget's just too big for the
genre typically
and
it's not going to work you want to be
able to have a general sense of in a
perfect scenario
who's on board to produce it direct it
act in it finance it is it from private
financiers is it from a studio
or is it streamer good to back it like
get a general sense i mean obviously
these things could be flexible
so i'm not saying being stuck on it
but knowing what
you're fulfilling a demand
you're not creating a demand
and i think that's important uh so on uh
on just kind of knowing where you
where you fit in
another part you also want to think
about is
what is it about this concept that makes
it unique
now i don't mean like making something
that's so like
esoteric and weird that it's unique
because it's just
strange
i mean like
if we've seen
a certain kind of bank heist
film what is it about it that's familiar
and what about it
is a new way in
and i could talk about tonally
conceptually the type of characters are
in it
the plot there's all sorts of room to
make it new
so it's that balancing act
and if there's not enough
unique elements
in the story
you know my worry sometimes is who's
going to want it
it just feels kind of what's out there
and
that's a problem you're going to put all
that work into writing it
yet there's 10 other movies like it that
just came out
so ideally i want to know the business
model like how does this work who would
want to be
part of this collaboration potentially
and then on a creative level
what makes this special
and
once we've achieved that and we know
there's space
then it works like i kind of look at
like there's a big white board okay and
the board has things already on it like
marked it up but there's a space on that
board where your movie fit or tv show
fits in
and the key is making sure the ideas
feel like there's some room for it
it's not redundant and it's not
just not
tenable in the it's in the business
model
so that really affects how
i think about potential
concepts to pursue developing into
scripts
have you ever had a client or potential
client say
are you gonna make this my career like
if i work with you and sign with you
can i be guaranteed by within this
amount of time
this will be my career i'll be a working
screenwriter podcaster
producer
no
i have never experienced that
approach i mean i'm sure some people
have it and it's fine
but typically i'm dealing with somebody
who's understands
the complexities of the
industry so someone who would ask those
questions that's that's a big that's a
newbie that's an amateur
i don't know i mean
you know that
that individual has the right to ask any
questions to a potential manager
i haven't encountered that and i don't
know if that means they're a newbie i
mean you know anybody
could
you know
address their concerns or their ambition
with the reps that they want to bring in
to their team it's totally fine
but i just haven't encountered
somebody who would put that on the table
would you say a lot of writers naturally
think this way in terms of
reverse engineering their path
so maybe they don't know how things are
going to turn out for them but they want
to try to see okay this is where i want
to be this is the level i want to be
working at with these type of players
now how do i get there
i think every client has their own
approach i think
as a manager
you want to
think about
how
a project
can go on a journey to
it becomes a you know a very
high quality
you know
experience once it's produced that it's
successful not just because it got made
critically and it has an incredible
return on the investment of who buys
into it
that's important to me
and i can't lose sight of the business
when i look at
you know any project any ideas that we
just start
discussing
now will writer have
the
the mindset to reverse engineer
their script maybe
maybe not maybe there's a theme they
want to explore
and that's totally fine i don't think
there's one way
to
bring something to life
you know i think that whatever
their
whatever they're prioritizing in the
inception of the idea
and then how it develops so
it's all across the board
what do you say to the writer who says i
just do writing i don't do anything else
i know my story is going to resonate
there's an emotional connection with the
protagonist
find someone else to produce it and
market it and do all the heavy lifting
but i just wrote it and that's all i
need to do well it's fine there's plenty
of producers out there who love
collaborating with great writers
i mean
it's a personal choice if somebody wants
to be a hyphenite
it's something that
if that's what matters to them
then they should make that their focus
if
if a client
just wants to write scripts
that should be their focus you know i
don't want to do anything but manage and
produce
i don't want to do any other capacity in
this industry and that's my choice so
i don't expect a writer to have to act
in it or direct it or produce or do
anything beyond
sitting down and you know
working on
developing new material
so you wouldn't be opposed to that if
you
had a potential client that said
i have things that i write i know
they're excellent that's all i do i
don't do windows i just i just write
that's all i do i mean that's totally
fine i i don't
value that type of client
more or less than somebody
who wants to take on additional you know
responsibilities
do you think it shows an attitude of
being inflexible or
they just do one thing and they don't
want to dilute what they do
i don't see any inflexibility at all
there's an entire
union the wga that protects writers
because this is a community that in a
lot of ways you know they they're like
this they build so much
incredible
you know stories and they are part of
this industry in the most meaningful way
there's no reason why a writer
has to direct it's it's you know it's a
choice my brother
is a writer who
ultimately you know he was he that's
what got him into the a lot of into the
game and now he's directing and then you
start he's also producing and he does
that and i have friends who are actors
who are also writers i mean
you know in the same way me you know as
a manager like there's something
compelling
about working with incredible
storytellers and that
uh is my passion and that's why i you
know every day i i get up and look
forward to the next you know
project and the next pitch or it get it
keeps keeps me moving you know that's
that energy that i get from my work
because it's so well suited for me
in the same way a writer
if that process
excites them
there's no reason to do anything else
so you can respect that someone who
knows what they're great at and they
know where their skills lie and they're
not going to deviate from that just so
that they can get a project moved along
or they if they're also you're okay with
people being as you say a
multi-hyphenate yeah i mean it's it's a
spectrum i mean there's people
who do everything and the and it's just
incredible what they they have so many
hats
but it's not for everybody and i totally
respect that i don't
look at it
negatively if somebody
really wants to just be a writer
because it's hard
to
to have that as
their singular focus so that doesn't
mean that it's that much easier
that comes with a lot of challenges to
be successful so
there's no expectation that somebody has
to direct and it doesn't also mean that
if you're just a writer
you're not being pragmatic because if
you write incredible work
you might find a director
that you love working with and now you
have a partner
and that director might not want to
write so that's like a perfect fit
what are those challenges you said there
are challenges that come with being
successful well you start with a blank
page
that's hard you know you have to build a
reality out of nothing
and
there might be an incredible director
who doesn't want to write a script
but you see their music videos or their
short films
and you think they have the right tone
so then you go
why don't we work together you don't
want to write you just want to direct
and
my my passion is writing scripts
and then you team up and you make
something really exciting
so you want your client
or potential clients to be comfortable
in what they do and their skill set
and you don't try to push them to
do more
if that's not within them
it's just what they're passionate about
i have clients that
create ip and they love
writing comics or making podcasts
that's all they want to do
they don't want to write scripts
and that's fine
because they're making something that
really emotionally moved me i don't need
anything
beyond what they already do they
they're already successful
being able to make
you know pieces of like art
that are meaningful
to
their audience and they
get excited about them and that's hard
that's not
easy so changing
the
changing them into hyphen nights
is really just they're about their own
personal interests and i can empower
somebody
who wants to expand new responsibilities
and support that
but at the same time it has to be a
natural progression of what they want to
do
you